13.6 billion years ago the dark scaffold
that supports all the regular matter in
the universe emerges Ablaze with stars
but how did this Stellar array evolve
into a structure littered with organized
galaxies
it seems they formed under constant
threat of Destruction
October 2020 astronomers discover a
monster lurking among the cosmic webs
earliest structures dating to 900
million years after the big bang a
supermassive black hole
six galaxies surround this Cosmic Giant
caught in its grip seemingly linked to
the Supermassive Black Hole by filaments
of the developing Cosmic web
it's like the universe has given
supermassive black holes in umbilical
cord
it's like an all-you-can-eat buffet
right there
super massive black holes or hungry
beasts they Feast on any matter that
gets too close to them
supermassive black holes are likely some
of the most powerful objects in the
universe they can be anywhere between a
hundred thousand to ten billion times
the mass of the sun
supermassive black holes have been a
nemesis for generations of scientists
not because of their fearsome nature but
because nobody knows how they grew so
large so early
I wish I knew we're supermassive black
holes came from if I knew I would have a
Nobel Prize hanging around my neck and I
would wear it every single day
one who deeply loves superpassive black
holes whose career is based on studying
supermassive black holes it is very
frustrating to not know where they come
from
regular Stellar black holes are the
collapsed cores of dead stars
ranging from 3 to 10 solar masses
but super massive black holes those are
a different Beast
13 billion years ago not enough Stars
had lived and died to build something as
huge as a supermassive black hole
now the cosmic web offers scientists
clues about the black hole conundrum
we now know supermassive black holes
grow among the lattice of the young
Cosmic web
gorging on the hydrogen gas that travels
along the filaments
at the same time when the cosmic web is
lighting up supermassive black holes
appear to be stealing star fuel from the
young universe
you might think that would kill a
growing Galaxy
and yet most mature Galaxies have a
supermassive black hole
they really dominate the physics of what
happens in the centers of galaxies and
even how galaxies can evolve
we think these Galactic Monsters have
been around from the start how then did
the webs young galaxies develop around
supermassive black holes
the Milky Way's supermassive black hole
is called Sagittarius A star it's around
27 million miles wide and weighs in at
just over 4 million solar masses
the environment around Sagittarius A
star is very Dynamic it can actually be
a really hellish place there's this
accretion disc that's full of plasmas
seated to thousands of degrees so you
wouldn't necessarily think that that's a
great place for Star information to
happen
but that's exactly where astronomers
decided to look
using the Atacama large millimeter array
or Alma for short scientists scanned the
heart of the Milky Way for dense cores
of gas and dust Stellar embryos
they found more than 800 within just a
thousand light years of Sagittarius A
star including more than 40 embryos with
energetic Jets blasting from their cores
The Telltale sign of the birth of stars
[Music]
find those stars there it's like hearing
babies Cries From A Wolf's Den
it's not the place you would expect this
to happen but in fact stars are forming
there now it's not as efficient as it is
out here in the suburbs where things are
quieter but it works
baby Stars igniting and thriving around
a supermassive black hole
the kind of hostile environment we know
existed in the young Cosmic web
star birth is a key part of kickstarting
young galaxies this evidence suggests
that star formation is more resilient
than researchers thought
and they've developed a theory to
explain it
gas and dust race around the black hole
in the accretion disk heated to
incredible temperatures plumes of gas
break off and blast into space the gas
rapidly cools collapses and forms baby
Stars these accretion discs are the most
chaotic of Stellar nurseries
ASM that you think is a violently
inhibiting star formation and at the
same time it's triggering the birth of
new stars
matter clumps at the cosmic webs
intersections feeding the supermassive
black holes around them Stars burst into
life slowly building galaxies this could
be how our own Milky Way formed among
the filaments of the young Cosmic web
but new research suggests that growth in
these baby galaxies requires murder and
Mayhem and without them we wouldn't
exist
the universe does need to churn things
up you need to break some eggs to make
an omelet you need to introduce some
chaos into your Galaxy to rapidly form
stars or grow black holes
smashing things together is how the
universe came to be
the Hubble Space Telescope discovers
many distorted galaxies Twisted battered
and torn
victims of violent collisions on a
cosmic scale
galaxies are never sitting quietly doing
nothing they're always undergoing change
they're constantly encountering and
slamming into and colliding with and
mixing with other galaxies
you can see images and Hubble of total
car wrecks of galaxies that are trying
to merge with each other
we know that galaxies Collide now
but what about in the early Universe
when the cosmic web was beginning to
take shame
astronomers study a strange Galaxy named
himiko born just 800 million years after
the big bang
three bright light sources suggest
intense star formation
detailed analysis reveals not one Galaxy
but three baby galaxies not yet fully
formed
scientists call these youthful star
systems Proto galaxies
the trio that make up himiko are in
mid-collision
computer simulations of the early
Universe suggest Proto galaxies smashed
together with frightening regularity
violent shake-ups trigger starbirth
proto-galaxies are rich in gas and when
they Collide and merge those gas clouds
Collide and collapse and form Stars
sometimes at prodigious rates and after
a billion years or so all of that
structure forms and you get a formal
Galaxy